كان من المقرر ان ينتهي اتفاق تصدير حبوب
الاوكرانيه في 19 من نوفمبر لكن تم تمديده
لمده اربعه اشهر لارحب الامين العام للامم
المتحده بهذا النبا ارحب باتفاق جميع
الاطراف على مواصله مبادره الحبوب في
البحر الاسود لتسهيل الابحار الامن لتصدير
الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه والاسمده من
اوكرانيا
تركيا كانت من الاطراف في المشاركه في هذا
الاتفاق مع الامم المتحده واوكرانيا
وروسيا اتفاق وفر في يوليو الماضي ممر
بحريا لاستئناف الصادرات من ثلاثه موانئ
في اوكرانيا تمديد هذه المبادره سيسهل
تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه لتعدوا الحبوب
الاخرانيه ضروريه لتثبيت الاسعار في
الاسواق الدوليه وامداد السكان الاكثر
عرضه لخطر الجوع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان احد مهندس هذا الاتفاق شدد على
اهميه الامن الغذائي تصدير اكثر من احد
عشره مليون طن من الحبوب في الاشهر
الاربعه الماضيه
ظهر اهميه الاتفاق للامن الغذائي العالمي
لعب انخفاض الشحنه من اوكرانيا في اعقب
الحرب دورا في ازمه اسعار الغذاء العالميه
هذا العام لتعد اوكرانيا من اهم منتج
الحبوب في العالم